اداء مشرف ركله جزاء ضائعه حظ النعاسر
وتسرع امام المرمى عبارات تلخص واحده لقاء
المنتخب السعودي بنظيره البولندي في سنه
جولات كاس العالم والذي خسره الاخضر
بهدفين مقابل شيء السعوديه لعبت مباراه
اخرى للذكرى الا ان التسرع ربما وغياب
التوفيق حل دون تسجيل المنتخب السعودي لاي
هدف خصوصا مع اضاعه اللاعب سالم الدوسري
لركله جزاء في الشوط الاول بعد هدف
المنتخب البولندي بدقائق وتاجل حسم التاهل
الاخضر السعودي حتى الجوله الثالثه
والاخيره من مرحله عندما سيقاب المنتخب
يوم الاربعاء المقبل وفي مباراه اخرى
خاسره المنتخب التونسيه امام نظيره
الاسترالي بهدف دون رد ليكون مصير تاهل
للنسور قرطاج في يد غيرها في الجوله
الاخيره ايضا لكن كيف كانت اجواء المباراه
الجماهيريه سنتعرف على ذلك بعد قليل منها
لو هيقعد الى صور المباركه اولا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يمتلك المنتخب السعودي العديد من الحضور
للتاهل الى دول ال 16 من مونديال 2012 حيث
يكفي للسعوديه الفوز مباراه القادمه امام
المكسيك باي نتيجه لضمان التاهل المباشر
دون النظر نتيجه المباراه الاخرى بين
الارجنتين وبولاندا كذلك فان التعادل لاهل
السعوديه بشرط خساره بولندا امام
الارجنتين بفريق اربع اهداف ايضا التعادل
السعودي مع المكسيك يؤهل المنتخب الاخضر
في حال انتصار بولندا على الارجنتين باي
نتيجه على كل حاله صدمه ايضا اجواء
المباراه بين السعوديه وفولندا ولكن هذه
المره من سلطنه عمان نتابع الاجواء مع عبد
الرحمن العصيمي
[تصفيق]
ايييه
حتى الثواني الاخيره من المباراه كان
الجمهور العماني متفاعلا مع مجريات مباراه
المنتخب السعودي امام بولندا ورغم الهزيمه
الا ان الجمهور العماني متفائل في تاهل
المنتخب السعودي امام المكسيك في مباراته
المقبله
[تصفيق]
كانت قويه كانت قويه بس ان شاء الله الكاس
السعوديه ان شاء الله
الاخضر السعودي كان مسيطر بالطول العرض
لكن مع الاسف الحظ لعب دور يعني زعلان
وننزل وقت فرحان شويه زعلان على النتيجه
بس فرحان ما شاء الله السعودي الاخضر
السعودي قدم همم بالحمام ملحمه كرويه بس
همم الحظ مرحله في هذه المباراه وان شاء
الله مع المكسيك انا باذن الله عندي تفائل
كبير انه بيفوزوا همم وبنتهى ان شاء الله
الدور الثاني ان شاء الله المنتخب السعودي
قديفه ما شاء الله وبيض يعني كل همم
الخليج والامه العربيه الاسلاميه اه اتوقع
انه يقدر يرجعوا في همم مباراه المكسيك ان
شاء الله
اليوم للاسف الحال في المنتخب السعودي همم
والفر فرصه همم البلينتي اللي ضاعت حتى
هسه اثبت شويه معنويا على
اللاعبين بس لكن يعني بشكل عام يعني هم
لعبوه ووفوا ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
كيف عيشه اجواء مباراه السعوديه بولندا
امس
عشت رياضيه اليوم يا سهام صباح الخير لكم
يعني قبل ما نحكي عن الاجواء الرياضيه راح
نحكي عن الاستوديو ههه راح نحكي عن عن
الثمن ملاعب الموجوده عندنا ستاد البيت
بيت الشعر اللي بنشوفه خلفي الذي يتسع الى
60,000 متفرج واستضاف المباراه الشهيره
الافتتاحيه بين قطر والاكوادور في
المجموعه الاولى يقع في مدينه الخور وليست
الدوحه استاد احمد بن علي التسالي 40,000
متفرج ويقع في مدينه ام الافاعي واستاد
الجنوب واستاد خليفه الاول واستاد المدينه
التعليميه
الديوكيشن ستلعب فيها المنتخب السعودي ضد
بولندا امبارح واستاد له السيل واستاد 74
استاذ الثمامه الذي
سيستقبل اليوم الفريق المغربي ضد المنتخب
المغربي عفوا ضد همم
بلجيكا واذا حكينا عن الاجواء يعني عن جد
كانت اجواء كثير كثير حماسيه
كاس العالم 2018 كرواتيا وفرنسا بتذكر
اذكر تماما كيف كان الوضع الكرواتيا بس
انه ال ال اللي شفناه امبارح كان مهيب
يعني عجبني اكثر اكثر شيء التنظيم كيف
الشباب السعودي والعائلات السعوديه كانت
تاتي عبر معبر سلوى يوصلوا بالحافلات همم
قدام الحافلات قدام الموجوده كانت تنقلهم
مباشره من المناطق السعوديه الى قطر
لمشاهده المباراه والحلو بالموضوع انه كيف
كان التنظيم يعني هلا همم كثير منهم طلعوا
من ساعات الفجر الاولى من المناطق
السعوديه تخيل شخص اجى من القصيم همم
لينتقل الى الدوحه لحضور هذه المباراه ان
كانت رائعه مثل ما حكيته قبل شويه كانت
يعني المباراه المنتخب السعودي لاعب
بطريقه عن جد رائعه تفضل
ليس انت جيت من فرنسا يعني شعرت انه فيه
وجود فرنسي واضح لدعم الديوك الفرنسيه في
المونديال خصوصا في مباراه امس
يا نادين
كلهم اجوا كان في كثير بيفوت عليه
مغاربه جايين من انحاء اوروبا اللي يشجعوا
المنتخب المغربي
مباريات بين المنتخب وسط الدوحه موجوده
اللؤلؤه موجود سوق واقف شاشات عرض كبيره
غير الفانزونس انتبهوا بتلاقي ال يعني
عجبني كيف الروح الرياضيه بين المشجعين
كيف بيكونوا موجودين جنب بعض مع انهم
فريقين وتنافسين في كاس العالم وبيلعبوا
مرات يعني شفنا السعوديه وبولندا موجودين
جنبا الى الملعب بحكي عن المناطق التي
تقام فيها
الاحتفالات والشاشات التي تعرض
همم المباريات فهذاك شيء جميل يعني روح
رياضيه مئه بالمئه في هذا البلد العربي
قطر وان شاء الله النجاح عربي في بلد عربي
وكاس عربي ان شاء الله كل التوفيق
للمنتخبات العربيه
ومن السعوديه الى تونس حيث خساره المنتخب
المؤلمه امام نظيره الاسترالي في مونديال
قطر حولت الشارع التونسيه من بروه الحماسه
والحلم الى حاله احباط خاصه مع تعادل سابق
مع الدنمارك احلام العبد الله يتحدث مع
تونسيين فور انتهاء المباراه
خيبه امل كبرى عاشها تونسيون اليوم بعد
هزيمه المنتخب الوطني التونسي امام نظيره
الاستالي في مباراه طالما علق عليها
التونسيون منذ ايام امال واحلام كبرى
كنت كنا نتوقعوا مقابله كبيره شفنا من
الاولاد ما انا اعطونا امل
الحقيقه ما عنده
الوقت كلهم
وكل عام وكل دورها طعام جاي عامل جاي
المره الجاي الواحد دراسه شيعيب واحنا
بنستنيه في المره الجاي خفت امل كبيره
اليوم في المباراه همم بون الاولاد عملوا
على اليهم همم ما له غزوهم همم نتيجه ما
تبعثش
فهمني
استراليا جاءتها فرصه واحده
ااااه كنا نحرمك واحنا دائما